الا الفوز الا الفوز
وبتظن ذلك بس يعني لازم نعرف لازم نعرف
احنا في فلسطين انه ترامبو كلينتون كلهم
يصبوا في صالح اسرائيل هناك احتمال كبير
ان تفوز السيده كلينتون لكن لا نعلم قد
يكون هناك مفاجات ويفوز السيد ترامب اعتقد
ان سيدك لن تتميز بصفات ايجابيه اولا انها
لدي خبره كبيره في السياسه الداخليه
الامريكيه بصفتها عضو كونجري السابق وايضا
لديها خبره في السياسه الخارجيه وقضايا
الشرق الاوسط لانها كانت تحتل مركز وزير
خارجيه امريكا صفر مميزه في كلينتون انها
تتميز بعلاقات دوليه موسعه سيما انها كانت
في وزاره الخارجيه خلال او ابان رئاسه
اوباما
السيء في كلينتون انها تتبنى وجهات النظر
تدعم
الفصل العنصري بين العرب والمسلمين توقع
فوز هلري كلينتون المتحده الامريكيه لم لم
تحكم بامراه كويس وهذا سيدلل على وجود
المراه داخل المجتمع الامريكي ويعطي فرصه
للمراه لحكم اقوى دوله في العالم ولا يؤخذ
عليها ماخذ التمييز بين النساء
حسب ما طلعت ورايت
بارجح انه الاحتمال الاكبر انها هي اللي
تفوت بالرئاسه الامريكيه وبيرجع ذلك الى
عده مسببات او عده ارهاصات من ضمنها
الخبره السياسيه اللي هي بتقود عليها
ما ننسى انه هي كانت وسيله خارجيه في يوم
من الايام عضو مجلس شيوخ كانت زوج زوجه
لرئيس امريكي فتلتين متتاليتين فاكيد الا
ما كانت اكتسبت خبره
سواء على المستوى الاداري او السياسي في
السياسه الامريكيه على الطرف الاخر ترامب
يمثل بشكل جديد
المال الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاول
مره يكون التنافس نوعا ما محسوم مقدمه
للسيده هلري ترامب واضح ان رجل اعمال واضح
ان تم تركيز اكثر على علاقاته الخارجيه
عملوا في امور المصارعه مشاكل مع النساء
ترامب يمكن المميز انه يعمل بصمت
بغض النظر عن انه خرج في الاونه الاخيره
بالتصريحات تثبت غير ذلك
السيء فيه انه ايضا
يقيم العدائيه
للفلسطينيين على ذات الخصوص وايضا للعرب
على ذات الشموليه والعموم صراحه لا اشعر
انه بيحمل اي مميزات مختلفه اوكي هو رجل
مال هو يملك المال ودائما يقولون في
السياسه من يملك المال يملك القرار لكن
ترامب غير مهيا امريكا بعظمتها تحتاج الى
من يملك الخبره الخبره في كافه الاتجاهات
ليس فقط من يملك المال